rocket league right now is in is in its
second PlayStation 4 beta the first beta
it was very successful and so today
we're going to show you what is in the
new beta along with some extra cool
stuff for the game spot audience that
will be in the final version but it's
not yet available in the beta one of the
things that we really like about rocket
League and working on is that we're
trying to approach it like it's a chess
type game so that on the surface it
seems like it's just cars playing soccer
and your goal is to hit the ball into
the opposite colored goal of your own
car but in reality what we're hoping
that people discover as they play is
that it's all about layers so while at
first you may just be hitting the balls
into the goals soon you realize that you
can also jump or double jump and if you
master the controls well enough you can
actually start to fly through the air
and you can do bicycle kicks and front
kicks and sidekicks you can do all sorts
of flips you can drive along the sides
of the walls and on the ceiling you can
be aggressive or defensive and all of
these elements taking together adds a
lot of strategy and a lot of competition
to what seems like a simple game but
actually is a quite complex despite it's
easy to play nature the game is
completely physics-based so where you go
and how you go is completely based on
how fast you're going and the angles
that you take things we wanted to make
sure that the game felt balanced so that
whenever you're playing that the cars do
what you expect them to do and that
you're not surprised by what happens
that you feel in control at all times
and one of the keys to doing that is
understanding your boost meter which is
in the the lower right-hand corner there
you can increase that by going over
those little lighted circles that you
see on the field and as that goes up
that gives you more boost eventually you
can actually go supersonic speeds if you
have enough of it and hold it down long
enough but allows you to do some really
cool goals
we also have a new item called season
mode which we're going to talk about
closer to release later the summer which
we're still working on but the season
mode is going to be we think a lot of
fun it's going to be much closer to
traditional season modes we find that
something like a madman or a fifa where
you can create your own team take them
through an entire season against other
teams you can customize what your team
looks your opponents will some will be
harder some will be easier you'll play
in all sorts of different stadiums we we
think that it's going to add a lot of
layers for players who before have only
ever thought of the game as a
multiplayer only game but we also wanted
to make sure that this time around we
have a lot of single-player options one
of the things that is not available in
the beta that we came here specifically
to show is the the ability to customize
your car in the garage so in the garage
mode in the final game you can see that
we have multiple car types will have at
least ten at launch and each one is this
is a very specific thing now is that
there are no stats or abilities
assigning these cars we wanted to keep
the game as balanced as possible and as
fair as possible so there are only real
differences in these cars besides their
look is where their hit boxes are
located so that's the slight alteration
that you'll see in how they play
otherwise we wanted to make sure that
it's all about personal customization
and expression and in the original game
all you could do was change your skin
here you can see now that we allow you
to change your paint color for both
primary and your accent color we also
have various paint types so we're still
working on how many we're going to have
in the finished version so don't
necessarily read too much into how many
appear on our list here but if you were
to select wood or glossy for example
those are different paint types we also
plan to include matt semi-gloss metallic
things like that the old up players
really customize the way that their
their car looks in a much more
interesting way than we had before we
also have new tires we have you can
update your rocket boost we have toppers
which are essentially
and that means that we have everything
from the mariachi hat which is a
favorite to the police the police cherry
top two other we have other all sorts of
facility we have silly things like a
traditional sombrero we have a whole
bunch of things that we don't want to
spoil the surprise on that are really
funny we also have things like taxi
toppers and pizza delivery toppers all
sorts of different things that will make
people feel like the cars their own and
antennas are also another good example
we have a ton of different countries in
there you can unlock other other flags
that are either funny or silly or look
really cool camouflage Flags traffic
flags team flags from our season mode
all sorts of things all in all we're
looking at more than a hundred and fifty
different items that you can customize
your car with at launch and we plan on
adding more things post launch as well
and one of the keys that we think to
keeping people involved is there's no
super complicated way and how these
unlock every time you play a game soon
as you're done you will unlock a new
item we didn't want to we wanted to make
sure that people were always looking
forward to the next thing and so we
think that as long as we're rewarding
them for playing the game that will keep
them interested and that's rocket League
we hope you liked what you saw we have a
lot more to show you as we get closer to
release later this summer exclusively on
playstation 4 4 consoles and also on PC
later in the year we really hope that
you have fun when you play the beta and
we'll see you there
you